-I did not realize this
about you,
because it strikes me
that you know what you like --
you´re very specific
about what you like --
but you are indecisive?
Is this true?
-Oh, my God, yes.
-Yeah.
Where does that indecision
most play out in your life?
-Well, whether or not
I was gonna do this show.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know, they --
"Larry, they want you
to do Seth Meyers."
"Um, uh, um...
Uhhh, I don´t know, maybe."
-[ Laughs ]
-No, I was very indecisive.
-Well, I´m glad
you decided to come.
How are you feeling
about the decision?
-Not good, not good.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-When I used to -- When I had
an apartment in New York
and I didn´t have any money,
I couldn´t decide what to eat.
I would go to the corner
of 43rd Street and 9th Avenue.
I would stand there
for 15 minutes,
thinking of the five restaurants
that I could afford to go to.
And it was so overwhelming,
I had to go back and go home.
-That was it?
-That was it.
-You couldn´t even pick
a restaurant?
-I couldn´t pick the restaurant.
-You´re back here
for the premiere of the show.
Coming from Brooklyn,
growing up in Brooklyn,
do you have any nostalgia
for being back in New York?
-[ Laughs ]
-[ Chuckling ] No?
No nostalgia for your youth?
-I-I-I don´t get that way.
You could put me back
in my own bed,
it wouldn´t make a difference.
[ Laughter ]
No, Brooklyn was a good place
to grow up, though.
-How so?
-Well, it was fun.
You know, you played baseball
on concrete.
That was fun.
[ Laughter ]
But there was no nature
in Brooklyn.
You know,
the only grass I ever saw
was on the divider
of the Belt Parkway.
-[ Laughs ]
-That was it.
And you know,
there were no flowers.
Just artificial ones
and artificial fruit.
Every apartment had
artificial flowers
and artificial fruit.
People took great pride
in their artificial fruit.
The greatest compliment
you could give someone
is to take a bite
of their artificial fruit.
[ Laughter ]
Accidentally, thinking
it was real fruit.
They would go crazy.
They´d remember it for years.
"Larry, remember the time
you took a bite of the apple?
The artificial apple?"
-Yeah.
-I couldn´t smell
the flower anyway,
because I was born
with the ability
to only smell disgusting things.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Immediately,
if you walk in a room,
can you clock it right away?
-A lilac, you could shove
up my nose, nothing.
Urine and B.O., I can smell
from three blocks away.
-It´s a gift.
-Yeah, it´s a gift.
-This is very strange to me,
because there are people
who actually are
such a fan of yours,
they have gotten
Larry David tattoos.
-Mm-hmm.
-These are real tattoos
that I´m showing.
There is one that someone got.
[ Laughter ]
There is another one.
Have you met these people?
Have you ever
crossed paths with them?
-I have crossed paths, yes.
-Are they excited to meet you?
-First of all,
here´s the thing about that.
You know, people who are fans,
once they meet me,
they´re so disappointed
so quickly.
-Yeah.
-It´s unbelievable.
You know, like --
in two minutes,
you can see -- you can see
their -- their face.
It´s a disappointment
etched on their face.
It´s like, "This is the guy
I wanted to meet?"
[ Laughter ]
"There´s nothing to him.
There´s nothing."
"What, am I crazy?"
You know?
-Could you date a woman
who had a Larry David tattoo?
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, it would be
interesting sexually.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-You start to get into it,
and all of a sudden,
you look down,
you see that on her shoulder.
[ Laughter ]
It would be like
making love to myself.
[ Laughter ]
Which I have done
a couple times.
[ Laughter ]